hallo und herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video über ein neues team programm
namens face ray mir wurde ganz oft
zugesendet hey luca es gibt da so ein
programm du wolltest du eigentlich mal
aufhöre mitterfels kann weil du dich
nicht mehr zeigen wollte so dieses
programm synchronisiert deine bewegungen
und deine augen und den mund auf
verschiedene figuren u
ich habe auch gestern schon gesehen dass
oder vorgestern oder fahre ich weiß es
nicht das schaffe dazu auch ein video
hochgeladen hat ich bräuchte link von
shuffles video und an die beschreibung
damit da keiner denkt sich das irgendwie
danach mache ich fand's cool und wollte
selber ausprobieren oder man vielleicht
sollte es einfach mal film wenn ich das
selber ausprobieren
das ganze ist noch in der beta-phase das
sieht jetzt vielleicht daran dass ich
jetzt relativ schnell rede
beispielsweise und dieser fuchs gar
nicht hinterherkommt allerdings solche
bewegungen wie wenn ich mich mal hier
zur seite kippen oder auch nach hinten
die verbindung von muss mich wieder
kurze hinsetzen
vielleicht hat das wieder so und ich
finde auf jeden fall schon richtig cool
und ich wollte ich einfach mal ein
kleiner einblick geben was man mit dem
programm alles machen kann
ihr könnt euch selber download des
kostenlosen 993 kein ding ich hab es
auch gekauft und ich wollte einfach mal
testen weil das relativ cool ist es ist
wirklich noch eine beta phase man muss
da nicht viel erwarten aber man kann
doch auch skype an wänden und leute
verarschen und alles mögliche machen
wir können jetzt gleich mal in der apps
avatar und background klicken dann
können wir beispielsweise auch den hier
auswählen
habe ich das richtig cool vor allem
dieser hund gefällt ihnen am besten
oh mann ich habe einfach mega viel spaß
damit und ich lasse euch einfach daran
teilhaben ich hab jetzt gedacht ich war
noch ein video heute einfach und zeigt
ein paar sachen bei facebook hi
ihre augen sind bisschen kobelt so weit
wir können natürlich auch anderen
background nehmen zwar finde ich dieses
appartement ganz cool und jetzt wenig
auch ganz cool finde ist das ist richtig
cool ich mag diese apple wohl aber ich
hab allerdings war nicht immer ein
stückchen heran
hallo
herzlich willkommen zum einem neuen
kanal ein neuer kanal heißt beauty passt
oh mann ich könnte mit den ganzen tag
spaß haben den haben wir hier noch alles
habe auf jeden fall richtig viele leute
wir können auch einfach mal den lava
baron nehmen
ich werde euch eure oben bürgern
verbindung von sowie in wien noch als
möchte ich alle zeit damit das ganze
selbst ausprobiert wenn ich einkaufen
wollte müsste natürlich nicht kaufen es
ist wie gesagt alles noch eine beta
phase ich würde doch erstmal warten bis
das ganze fällig ist man muss dann noch
ein avatar customization das habe ich
selbst noch nicht gesehen man kann hier
man kann das selber heranzoomen und
alles hätte vielleicht ich weiß nicht ob
er das menü gattin abzuwarten kannte so
ich möchte noch ein bisschen näher dran
haben und ein bisschen mehr nacht so da
kann man so ein paar sachen machen
station machen wir mal einfach den haben
wir noch wir haben hier bestimmt noch
ein paar andere lady catherine das ist
sondern fuchs tante
lkw bei mir selber in den augen oh mann
ich möchte gar nicht mehr so lange hier
mit rumspielen weil das echt ich weiß
nicht ich weiß nicht mal ob ihr diesmal
dieses video wenn es euch gefällt dann
bitte gebt den daumen hoch weil ich
denke dass es wieder total viele
displays bekommt diesem und in grüner
synchronisation passt nicht so ganz weil
ich die ganze zeit zu halb von mikroben
und auch meinen mund beim sprechen immer
nie so weit aufmachen
also ihr könnt schon sehr nicht also
jemand synchronisation passt schon auch
mit den augen hier so wenig an aber auch
als 2 okay das kann nicht erkennen warum
nicht also man kann auf jeden fall ein
paar coole sachen die mitmacher mensch
gefallen hat würde ich mich alle diese
diese frau so ein bisschen komisch mir
gefällt immer noch am meisten dieser
fuchs zu mal ganz kurz den fuchs wieder
raus damit wollen wir den tag
also der gefällt mir immer noch am
meisten wenn es euch gefallen hat und
ihr eventuell mehr von solchen komischen
sachen wollt also ich weiss nicht mehr
damals auch mal video zum sperma
simulator gemacht oder solche sachen
dann schreibt sie auf jeden fall in die
kommentare und zeigt es mir vor allem
mit einem daumen hoch und wir halten
gegen die ganzen händler dagegen die was
der gegner wenn ich spaß haben ich hatte
einfach nur gedacht kommen mir gefällt
das ganze ich nehme das mal auf es wird
mir aufgeschrieben und ich hab's bei
staffel schon auf dem kanal gesehen das
denn geschafft als video und in der
beschreibung verlegen falls die damals
vorbeigucken volt bei ihm läuft das
ganze ein bisschen flüssiger bei mir
sehen wir zum beispiel gerade gar keinen
mund zu kriegen weil ich so schnell
räder dieser unter gar nicht
hinterherkommt das ist echt cool wieder
bei sozial wir sehen uns beim nächsten
mal wieder